foreign
[Music]
murderheart posted the little um the
little um Avatar review it says little
Tom says hello
all right
I can't remember what I made when I made
little Tom say what does he say I don't
know I don't I can't remember what it is
yeah yeah yeah it's something that you
sailed it looks just like you I have to
say yeah okay
every ball [__] with a wife
beater looks like me the mustache
well no I mean that boy is I'm becoming
a stereotype
you could be like another one I'm a
stereotype bald [__] yeah ball
[__] with them yeah
laughs
okay well yeah
that's that's that was your decision so
[__] happens though I mean no you look
at like you look at like yeah like I
said I never it's weird because I never
knew you with um facial hair for like a
really long time and I was sitting there
going I don't know how that's gonna work
out but actually it did work out yeah
it's my descent into evil yeah yeah
you're descent you don't have that
farted yeah to be honest maybe maybe I
Aces
it's a slightly less evil
maybe that could be all right so today
was actually a pretty good episode I've
watched this thing twice tried to do a
[__] deeper analysis of it
and um it's a real good episode
um the witnesses [__] describe some
pretty creepy phenomenon it kind of
rings true to me
uh after
[__] Mammoth Mountain which Jane
wrote a book about what happened to me
and my family when I was a kid and it's
just like especially the piano thing but
nothing like that happened to me but it
just that's like something a poltergeist
would do there was some creepy [__] in
this one I'm surprised I didn't remember
this one better right it's weird [__]
happens in it and then a little boy is
seeing gabo he called him gabo gable
gable yeah like g-a-y-b-o Gable that's
what he called him although I think on
the on the Wikipedia page they spelled
it g-a-b-e-l yeah yeah that's what he
was saying yeah
and it was some man he was seeing
talking to
but nobody else could see him as his
[__]
imaginary friend he insisted that he
could see this dude
and then uh weird phenomenal happened we
liked how we liked how the little boy
that was playing the kid he looked
slightly older than the real kid because
I think the real kid was supposed to be
three
and that kid was four or five I think
but um he had like a really funny like a
really cute like little kid voice and
like just the way he said everything I
was just like it's like it made me laugh
every time he said something yeah he's
white heel right here he white heel yeah
Jenny says I bet you pookie talks that
way if she could talk
he's not a little kid anymore Pookie
would be a teenager actually late teens
probably yeah don't they yeah yeah she's
always gonna be a little baby yeah okay
she's always like a little brat yeah
running around running in the closet
yeah interactive kitty yeah he's always
underfoot she is yeah she's probably
well she was in here a second ago yeah
tearing the rug up looking at the lights
going what the [__] is up with this yeah
she gets mad yeah she got mad and left
because we weren't talking to her Max I
won't let her tear up boots
hahaha
get on the closet yeah she wants to be
shut in the closet yeah she knows that
the closet she thinks she can open the
closet from what's inside we Tom thinks
this was actually very insightful and he
said well maybe she thinks that she can
get out because she can get in and out
of the bathroom cabinets yeah like
easily like she can open them with her
little Pond she can get back out she can
just push him so I think that she thinks
that she can get out of the closet too
yeah because it's those shutter doors
though you can't push him but you can't
push him out she wouldn't be strong
enough to push him out yeah but maybe
she does think that because she's like
well I can get out of the cabinet like
and she likes being shut up in the
cabinet yeah but she can get out but I
just you know I don't know maybe that's
what it is uh Zach says hey [__]
what's up I'm frustrated as [__] today
then murdered murder when it said Zach's
on the war path yeah
what are you frustrated about that case
region levels too low is gastrogen level
he's too low yeah is that what maybe
it's real high it's probably really high
it's what it is the price super hot
yeah thank you Tom yeah what's your
what's your gastrogen level today my
gastrogen level is non-existent right
now I don't even have to I don't even I
don't even have estrogen at all
just pure testosterone and progesterone
hey yeah yeah yo I can't reach climax
can I just go there I just [__] until I
get pissed off and then just jump off
done with this [__] two hours later yeah
Jenny knows pretty much
yeah you
get that mad about it you don't get that
man no I mean you still have a good time
yeah there's just not enough estrogen in
your system to do the whole floaty thing
and like [__] and then let it go
there's none of that it's just focus
focus I just start thinking about
mathematics
massively as [__] just math and machines
machines yeah
math and machines yeah and they're
watching me everybody's watching me the
machines are watching you just
everything's watching me yeah that's
probably not good no no the paranoia of
being a male yeah well hyper masculine
hyper masculinity that's not good not as
bad as Tran though don't be like lashing
out no no no it's our [__] like that
it's okay
I'm on 500 Meg's a test if that's part
of it
and then I'm going on MPP a couple days
yeah it's gonna be good though I love
MPP
yeah murder Hornet said lay off Trend
yeah yeah
please I'm not going back on trend I
told you all my gay porn star and Buddy
[__] came at me he's like dude I got
a [__] ton of trend man enough to last
both of us for years I said what he said
yeah I got somebody else's shipment and
I said did you get the MPP he goes no
but I got a [__] Year's worth of TR I
got several years worth of trend and I
said oh no I ain't doing it says Jenny
says no yeah no he's like oh come on man
come on man he wants to go get werewolf
and [__] go beat up twinks and [__]
we'll go fight the whole bar man we'll
get some tweaks and make porn no no no
dude
because sounds like a plan yeah he's got
to take train to get gay
that kind of that almost sounds like a
country song yeah I'm not gay without
training not gay without Tran
gotta take a whole bunch of traffic to
get gay enough to make the porn he's
crazy got a good game oh muscle man yeah
time to make the porn yeah like time to
make some hate weakness if he comes more
because this is bondage porn
not normal porn
beating dudes up and [__] Zach says
isn't Tom gonna have to get his tubes
tied when you guys go all the way in
yeah on your on your new bed how am I
gonna get it yeah
[Laughter]
look man I'm here doing a [__]
serious [__] parapsychological
analysis this [__] case you guys
yeah because yeah talking all this gay
[__] you brought it up I'm pretty
sure yeah
I mean you you think I don't remember
but I'm like dude it was like two
minutes ago that's your job I gotta try
to flip it around
it's a show business man you know like I
said I missed my calling as a [__]
comic you know that's what I do you did
yeah just you have to have a lot of
hatred and anger to be a good comic see
that's the well that's why a lot of them
are like related nuts yeah
which is sad well like I said it's you
know it's a defense mechanism being
funny a lot of people not always but
you're diffusing inner conflict yeah
yeah yeah yeah
uh Tammy said that'll be the day the
show is serious right it's like we can't
I can't be serious I mean I can't no
they've been many times we do serious
[__] here with serial killers and stuff
yeah some of the shit's a downer yeah
yeah without without us [__] around
and making jokes this [__] would be
depressing as [__] yeah I do kind of
feel like some people people some people
I mean I don't really get that much um I
don't really get any complaints that
much anymore but every now and then like
you get a comment it's like oh you know
you guys are making jokes on this show
about murders or whatever and it's like
really disrespectful and like you know I
get that some people think that but
we're not making fun of murders we're
not like making fun of the victims or
something like that it's just like
sometimes you just gotta make jokes
about [__] because it's like so horrible
and like so depressing you know what I
mean you gotta [__] laugh so you
don't cry you know man's inhumanity
Demand right yeah
uh Zach said it's also why so many
Comics make the best dramatic actors yes
exactly I think that's why because a lot
of them have like a lot of uh inner
turmoil let's put it that way you know
what I mean all right so uh so let's
talk about some ghosties how about it
okay yeah yeah so this at least we can
be funny on this one without feeling too
bad I hope you got hurt nobody got hurt
on this one
um but yeah so this episode in case you
didn't know is from season five we're
still working our way through season
five uh this is episode seven and it's
called back from the grave not to be
confused with Echoes from the grave
which is a totally different one than we
already did we're Shadows from the grave
or hands from the grave
Graves from the grave
dicks from the grave mouth from the
grave it's just real porns porn
yeah kuchacha from the grave
I mean you know yeah it's all from the
grave yeah we're all going well how
about but you know they they should have
had someone going to the Grave too yeah
from the grave to the Grave yeah yeah
back from the great brothel of the Grave
sure yeah that's what [__] Ed gean
was all about yeah that's all the people
that are like he just saw the cemetery
as a brothel
[Laughter]
Sebastian says and we're not making fun
of porn either
uh murder Hornet said I'd like to go
clubbing with Tom and we get in a bar
fight yeah you probably would yeah it
[__] really would get in a bar fight
he's depending on the night he's like
dude we'd get a trend out man we'll
fight the whole [__] bar man we'll
drive them all out until the cops come
and I'm going yeah that was on Trend
what a good idea yeah yeah wait a minute
hold on this is why this is how dude's
getting shot and he's like yeah and
arrested yeah because he's yeah you know
it literally [__]
go [__] just look up Trend stories I
swear to God man it's really like if you
pulled that [__] on me I would just like
you would call me and be like hey I'm in
jail like help me out and stuff I'd be
like bye click
you sort that [__] out all kind of [__]
on YouTube search for Trend stories and
[__] dudes do all kinds of [__]
weird [__] on it
and uh no
at the time it seems like a good idea
but a lot of things seem like a good
idea it feels real good but then later
you're like why the [__] did I do that
that was stupid as hell yeah
yeah it's not for human consumption but
dudes are taking it anyway it's for
cattle you know but
so you're like a Ware cow yeah a werecat
no like a minute
I prefer wear cow
Minotaur I felt like a werewolf I saw
myself as a werewolf
you would yeah but looking back on it I
wasn't a werewolf I was the Goblin from
[__] Spider-Man yeah
yeah but not as fun as that sounds yeah
no
[Laughter]
murder Harden said Jen be like you hear
that Tom's like hear what then dial tone
yeah yeah that's what it is and it's no
joke you can just run through if dudes
aren't working out and especially if
they're not on gear you just run through
them like children they're like
cardboard cutouts of men
you just whip two dudes asses they were
six Footers Just Whipped two of their
asses back after back to back in the
nightclub on the same night
one after the other
well the first one I didn't whip is that
just grabbed him so [__] grabbed him
by the throat just crushed him and then
he ran off with his friends he didn't
want to fight the other one I fought
just beat him like a [__] rag doll
and kind of Justified one of them
grabbed Jen's ass I [__] went right
on him bow and then the other one was
just harassing Jen and
soap and you just get a real [__]
defensive you know you're like protect
the women just Wade right in there's no
decision being made just tread makes
that decision for you you just do it
it's
bull testosterone turned into a [__]
steroid and after about [__] three
months of that [__] I'd been doing it
for about five months straight you're
[__] not sane
not saying no your hormonal [__]
levels are [__] just outside the
human [__] range
it's it feels great you feel like
Superman but you're not you're the
Goblin
and everyone else around you yeah bro
everybody's Reverend's terrified of you
you know I think I'm gonna cut that
dude's head off hold my beer you know
you're literally like that yeah pretty
much and then like if you try to like
talk him down he just like thinks you're
crazy he's like what are you picking on
me for you crazy yeah we gotta cut this
motherfucker's head off you can't let
him just run around I mean you're with a
head yeah you're either you're really
evil you're running around with a head
you kind of stop but you know your your
instincts are telling you to do things
that are [__] psychopathic
and it's just [__] notorious for it I
mean if you ever went on that again I
would have to get like some tranquilizer
darts so like I could just go like from
across the club and like put you down
like a tiger on the like a lion on the
Serengeti you're not supposed to be
taking it longer than [__] eight nine
weeks you know ten weeks maybe
but I took it and I was like oh no this
is fine no I can I can handle this I
just kept taking more and more five
months later I'm still on it
yep that was a poor decision oh lunatic
that was a poor decision and you think
you're totally fine yeah well that was
the scariest part it's like you couldn't
be talked to or even you think you're
fine like everyone was telling you like
you were acting like a [__] but like
you didn't believe them so yeah Zach
said also I'm frustrated because I want
to make a career shift in doing local
filmmaking jobs but I have no idea how
or where to start I mean I kind of feel
like probably the best thing to do is if
you know anybody that's into that or if
there's any kind of like group or
anything like that that does anything
related to that like maybe join that so
you could like get some
uh you know like know some people that
are into it like that can help you out
because I kind of feel like networking
is like more important than anything
you know probably more important than
even like knowing your [__] is like
knowing the right people
that makes like a big difference just
saying I didn't really wanna
um acknowledge that so much because I
don't like meeting people that I don't
like every day I got with people but
it's true like who you know is a lot
more important than what you know in a
lot of situations
um so yeah where we got distracted again
like talking [__] talking about the
title of this yeah so we're in for a
long night
okay we got a decent crowd we can start
yeah yeah okay so back from the grave
like I said
season uh five episode seven so this one
took place in North Carolina in
Winston-Salem actually
um so at the beginning did they say like
the cemetery that it was at did they
call it Lincoln Cemetery yeah maybe
something like that I could I was like
details like locations so I can go right
over
and I got their names like the the
woman's name was Jamie Bruce and her
husband boyfriend's name was uh Aaron
and uh they lived in the Jackson Acres
neighborhood like they bought a house
there so this was like they'd been
together a long time but this was like
the first house that they had ever
bought so this took place in Fall of
2008.
so the two of them have two kids uh
Lacey who was one so she was like a baby
and then they had a boy that was named
Mason who was three I have a nephew
named Mason actually
so they said around they said the best
thing about this neighborhood was that
there was like a lot of local parks so
they used to always like take the kids
out for walks in the Parks and
everything like that so their favorite
Park which was just a few houses down
from there from their house was attached
to a graveyard now they said that sounds
kind of weird but it was a really nice
they said it was a family-owned
graveyard it was like really nicely kept
up and it was like a really nice park
next to it so they would like go for
walks and take the kids and everything
like that so they said what they started
to notice
that when they were taking the kids for
walks through this graveyard that Mason
the three-year-old kept looking like he
was
seeing something like seeing something
or like talking to somebody or that
there was somebody there you know I mean
like he'd be stopped and be staring over
like a tree like there's somebody over
there and his mom said that he was like
really seemed like really uncomfortable
you know because like she asked me just
like hey bud what like what are you
looking at are you okay or something
he's like I want to go home you know
what I mean so he was like freaking out
so they showed they you know this kind
of is jumping ahead a little bit but
they showed like a um
what looked like a civil war soldier
like kind of popping out from behind the
trees they're implying that that was
what the little kid was seeing but
obviously we don't know if he saw that
or not he wasn't on the show was he just
the Mom and Dad yeah if the mom and dad
were and I think like a friend of theirs
that also like saw some of the [__] was
on there too and the paranormal
investigators were on there but no the
kids weren't on there
so um much like a lot of the families
it's very very common with families on
this show
is that the husband like the mom is a
stay-at-home mom and the dad works
nights so he works like at a trucking
company and they said sometimes he was
he worked in his whole like Dawn until
like sunrise
so one particular night you know the mom
of the kids are home all by themselves
and the baby starts crying and then I
guess like the lights are kind of
flickering and all that kind of stuff
and then so
the mom goes in to like check on the
kids I think they're both in the same
room and Mason says that a man came out
of the mirror like in their bedroom hmm
and of course you know the mom doesn't
believe this but the kid is like super
insistent and she's like well where's
the man now you know what I mean just
like well he was just here he just came
out of the mirror you know what I mean
so obviously you wouldn't believe that
if like a three-year-old kid told you
that you're like okay kid whatever
he's imagination you don't think he
imagined it yeah yeah yeah or he dreamed
it yeah and that's the thing like a few
hours later because she said that the
little kid wouldn't go to sleep until
his dad came home so it's like his dad
came didn't come home until like a few
hours later so as soon as the dad comes
home
um you know she told Aaron the dad like
about the kid's dream quote unquote even
though I'm pretty sure the kid said that
he saw it like and he was awake but you
know like I said they didn't really
think anything about it they just
thought oh he's having nightmares or
stuff even though they said the kid
didn't usually have nightmares and this
was like very unusual for him so they
did think it was a little weird but you
know they just had some wild ass dreams
when I was a little kid they were real
yeah he's messing with Spock because Fox
going like that
he's not that sexy what yeah he is okay
Poky nose
[Laughter]
yeah you said you had some wild ass
dreams when you're a kid I had one when
I was a little kid
um where I dreamed that I was in bed and
woke up and inside my dark room at night
all right and I saw a woman walking
towards me it was Endora from [__]
Bewitched you know Samantha's mom
she's walking towards me in this [__]
green and blue witch's gown that she had
cool you know what I mean behind her was
like a light and smoke and [__] it was a
real like something out of a movie and
she's walking towards me she had
something in her hand she's holding it
like this and then she's coming closer I
realize it's a bottle it looks like a
dam
just like a bottle of like a Genie
bottle or not like a poison bottle or
like a like a bottle of [__] brandy
or something okay it was all pretty and
she's showing it to me like that and I'm
leaning forward to see what it is she's
trying to show me and it was red and
swirled and it looked like uh glitter
and stuff in there and it all started to
swirl around inside the bottle and it
condensed into a skull and crossbones
and it [__] scared the [__] out of me
because I thought she was trying to
poison me and I woke up and I was in bed
but I already thought I was awake in bed
yeah I thought she walked into my yeah
I've had dreams yeah and Dora tried to
poison me
from Bewitched that's kind of cool
though like the way you described it
that actually sounds kind of awesome
look like something out of the dam
haunted house the Haunted Mansion from
um Disneyland because I was in
California at the time as a little kid
and it's probably it looked like like
that kind of like you know the the
woman's head inside the globe and yeah
that was kind of like a shirt forever it
was kind of the Ambiance of the of the
scene
that's pretty awesome but of all peoples
and Dora
[Laughter]
The Wiz she was a witch yeah an old
witch
uh so yeah so like I said they probably
just thought this was a dream of like
you know the kid Kevin like a guy coming
out of the mirror next morning though
um Jamie
she's like in the kitchen like she hears
some stuff like she's walking out of the
kitchen and then she hears some stuff in
the back in the like back in the kitchen
like somebody's in there you know I mean
like somebody moving around or something
and so like she turns around and goes
back in there and all the cabinet doors
are open I don't know why like ghosts
always do this kind of [__] or like
Poltergeist always do this like look to
open all the cabinet doors yeah but
that's very very kind mine didn't do
that no I'm just saying you see that a
lot do you see it a lot yeah you see it
a lot I'll like uh cabinet doors open
and like all of them being open like
suddenly yeah so um she's like well the
first thing I thought was maybe I did
that she's like even though you know she
knew damn well she didn't do that but
you know she was just trying to like
dismiss it you know what I mean
and then later on she said she's given
Mason a bath
and she left him for a second like to go
out in the hall like and get a towel
from the hall closet and the door to the
bathroom like closes by itself and then
she hears Mason talking to somebody like
rolls seriously she said she couldn't
make out what he was saying but he was
definitely having a discussion with
someone I don't think she said she could
hear the other end of the conversation
but she could hear him talking and he
sounded like he was very seriously
talking to somebody
so she comes back in and she's like well
who are you talking to
and he says he's talking to Gable
talking to Gable yeah gable gable yeah
and um she's like oh is that like your
invisible friend is like no he's real
and then she's like he was right here
but then he left that's what he said
um so
so then she's like well where'd you hear
that name from
and he says well Gable told me that that
was his name
and you know and she's like oh well okay
well he's not real though and then Mason
goes I thought this was funny because
like or the kid playing Mason he goes
he's so real yeah I like that and it's
like I just died laughing I'm like oh my
God that kid's hilarious he's so real
real as [__]
I mean you know
um so they actually they go out to
um the living room so Jamie is like
telling Aaron she's like this is like
some weird [__] right here she's like
this kid like is insisting that there's
a man that she's like talking that he's
like talking to a man
so they both start talking to him
instead of like okay well who's this
Gable person and they're like well where
is he right now like now they're out in
the living room
and then this was this was like creepy I
thought they did a good job like on the
scene because they're like
well where is he right now and the kid
points like back into he's back in the
bedroom you know what I mean it's just
like the way he did it I was like ooh
that would be a creepy if your [__]
kid did that he's just right back there
like in points so his dad says well why
don't you go get him I want to talk to
him
and then so Mason goes he tottles back
into the bedroom and then comes back out
and obviously he's by himself
but they're like well I thought you were
gonna go get cable where is he and he's
like he's white heel yeah yeah he's
white heel yeah he's just white heel
hahaha
and I was like would you would you [__]
your [__] pants if like your
three-year-old kid was like it's like
it's right here he's right here like you
can't see him obviously he's right here
he sees you he said yeah he sees you he
sees you yeah little kids have an
imagination though there's no telling
them they do that's what I mean that's
why you can't take any I mean little
kids say creepy [__] all the time all
the time and you never really know
because I know that a lot of people
think it's like oh the kid's seeing
ghosts and [__] like that because of all
this creepy [__] they're saying but I
don't know like you said like kids have
a lot of imagination so more than you'd
think it's really hard to tell like if
they're just making stuff up animals
have imaginations
I just saw a clip of a monkey picking up
a leaf and pretending like he's working
on another monkey's eye and put that
leaf down and grab another leaf and put
it and the other monkey's like going
yeah fix it fix it
kicks in his eye with a tool yeah and he
didn't put that he didn't put the leaf
inside the other monkey's eye they were
monkeys they were baboons what do you
just pretending just pretending he was
pretending to fix it pretending to fix
it with a with two different leaves
a blue I could agree one and a brown one
that's so funny and only an only
imagination
and then the other
baboon is like yeah he's fixing it
I've been using tools yeah look at him
go look at that sucker go yeah
wrong with his eye probably pretending
what Pookie pretends she imagines stuff
if somebody's taking a picture of it
with a phone so these baboons evidently
are around people a lot so
maybe they were inspired
by seeing human beings use little tools
yeah so they're just down grab a leaf
and pretend rub his eyes and then grab
another leaf and make him just shapes
over the eye yeah because they're good
at um you know mimicking other yeah
Behavior yeah like people's behavior and
other Apes Behavior
but yeah so the kids basically like he's
standing right here right now and he
sees you which like I said holy [__] I
would probably like pee my pants if
somebody said that so um Jamie said she
she actually had a good idea she's like
so she wanted to know if the kid was
just making this up or if there was
really somebody there
so she asked Mason she's like why don't
you ask Gable what five plus six is
because she knew damn well that the kid
couldn't do math right
um hey thank you very much John
Robertson hey guys love the show a cool
video idea would be the life of Vincent
Price I noticed he's one of the only old
school horror actors you haven't covered
yet that I know of yeah we probably
should do no we didn't do Vincent Price
did we we did Bella Lugosi and Boris
Karloff like on One show but I'm pretty
sure we didn't do Vincent Price and I do
kind of want to do a show about it first
time I've I've remembered that name this
must it must be a long time listener
first time
um Super Chat Giver I don't remember
that day do you remember that name uh
well on Robertson yeah okay it must have
been a while back so I'm gonna write
that down because I'm gonna put that in
the poll for next week because I think
we were talking about it when we were
talking about doing the bellagosian um
okay and the uh Boris Karloff show Jen
I'd love to do that she loves being
surprised I mean I got it she can dig up
everything about that dude and he's like
really interesting like you know what I
mean I love that him and his wife did a
cookbook later on because he was like
rolling to Gourmet cooking and stuff I
just think that's adorable
but uh but yeah so um so the mom
asked Mason yeah ask Gable what five
pluses six is because she knew this I
mean the kid's three he couldn't do any
[__] math you're right like so thank
you murder Hornet just following the
flashbulb tree
yeah keep it going yeah
[Laughter]
so she said then
um the kid actually kind of consulted
with the invisible who's this that was
like standing next to him and then he
goes over to the Bookshelf and pulls out
they had like a you know like World Book
Encyclopedia or whatever the [__] and he
pulls out Volume 11 and hands it to his
mom and they were like what they're like
holy [__] there really is a ghost in our
house this is like [__] freaky
so um they have this friend a neighbor I
guess who hangs out there all the time
his name is Pam and I guess she was they
interviewed her on the show too because
she was talking about how weird this
[__] kid was acting and it's like she
was starting to think that like the [__]
was haunted too so you know she's like
this kid really did believe that Gable
was real he was like super intense and
serious about it you couldn't like joke
about it or anything like that he was
like no he's real
so um Jamie you know like in kind of a
last-ditch attempt she's like okay maybe
the kid heard the name someplace else so
she goes to the kids school and talks to
Cuba's in preschool and goes to talk to
the teacher and asks her you know is
there anybody in this class with that
name or you know was it was it a story
was about that person or something like
that the teacher didn't know what she
was talking about so she's like yeah so
she didn't hear it he didn't hear it
there
so the story is true maybe the kid was
seeing gable gable gable gable yeah
he's white heel
but yeah that's how the kid talked and
it's just like it made me laugh like
every time the kid talked to him like he
had that funny little baby voice
um so wait a minute uh John Robertson
yeah it's been a while uh life's been
rough and I love Vincent Bryce too Jen
Tom loved that facial hair going on yeah
I guess it has been a while because yeah
you grew that a while back yeah it's a
while back Spock inspired me mirror
Spock yeah right a mirror top he's
mirror stuff
I have to try and I'm mirror now
yikes
[Laughter]
so you're you're much you're much better
now yeah it took me a couple months to
get back to normal I mean but it did
yeah it did but you still have your
moments but you learn bad habits you're
a lot better yeah because like before I
was just like I don't even know how to
deal with this situation this is [__]
freaking me out that was pretty when you
did your hair like that we have to give
you some braids I was thinking about
that I said well now that I've shaved it
back underneath though but I can still
break it down okay yeah well no I didn't
shave it but it's true I need to touch
that up for you yeah I know it's like I
get now it's like I wanted it shaved off
and now I'm too lazy to like [__]
yeah you never remind me like five
minutes to shave that so like then it
grows out and then it starts getting
gray so then I have to like dye it and
[__] like that it's like a whole it's a
whole ordeal but uh it's a lot cooler in
the summer though yeah because I gotta
do the [__] braids from the girl from
poly from NCIS or that chanted little
braids yeah yeah in the bags yeah yeah I
do like but I do like my hair braiding
yeah I can do all your hair little
braids like almost a little [__]
little dreads almost like little dreads
I have to pay somebody to do that yeah
we had to we'd hit the sub I can braid
my own hair but not that many a little
yeah we talk little fine braids yeah and
then to maintain that it'll probably
cost quite a bit wouldn't it yeah
because you have to be [__] redone
all the time so probably what I don't
know any of you braid sisters can give
us a price in the bottom how much would
it cost to keep that up I bet you it's
like a couple hundred dollars every two
or three months yeah I imagine so
probably expensive dude having your hair
did is not cheap yeah especially I mean
for guys I think it's cheaper but like
for women no way like especially if
we're getting like colors and cuts and
stuff like that it's like easily a
hundred dollars like at least well it's
long enough to braid yeah it definitely
is make your wigs a lot easier to do to
use vibrated be cooler yeah probably
okay we gotta get back to the show yeah
I was gonna say you're getting all
distracted distracted
[__] Friday yes I tracked this Friday
yeah I mean every show is sidetracked
yeah I mean not gonna lie but um sorry
about that well some people like it
though I mean I guess the people that
didn't like it have [__] off so I
guess yeah I guess I guess we're fine
um but yeah so what yeah there are there
read They're reading [__] uh
Wikipedia yeah I mean yeah just read
Wikipedia
so um so yeah so after Jamie finds out
that the kid probably didn't find didn't
learn the Gable name at school either
she's like she starts to believe well
maybe the [__] is real maybe it is a
ghost and then she starts feeling like
in the house like she starts feeling
like she's being watched but she can't
figure out if it's just because she's
starting to believe that the ghost is
real and she's like psyching herself out
or if there really is something in the
house
now one night a little bit later she's
talking on the phone to her friend Pam
and she hears noises in the house like
someone's in there and I'm pretty sure
well this was another time when like the
dad like I said the dad is always like
working night so he's always gone which
like I said is very convenient that
always happens on these shows dude's
always gone like all night before I
forget
Shauna does hair
yeah that's right I forgot we got hire
Sean
you can do it here yeah that gives them
aside money
I just want to go to her place something
yeah yeah
but um
yeah so she starts hearing noises in the
house and she thinks there's like an
intruder she's like it sounded like
heavy footsteps and she said it sounded
like
bike chains like somebody had bike
chains and they were kind of like
whacking them on the floor so yeah it
reminded me like the sound effect they
used in the show it kind of reminded me
of you know like in A Christmas Carol
when you know Jacob Marley comes in he's
dragging all the chains with the with
the weights and [__] on him it kind of
reminded me of that kind of noise that's
kind of what it sounded like but she
said it sounded like bike chains
so she goes up and checks and like the
kids are asleep so she has no idea like
who the [__] is making that noise and
she's like I think somebody's in the
house and so she's like looking all over
the house and she can't see anybody
obviously
um then she calls Aaron but of course
you know he's no help because he's like
well are you sure you heard something
I'm like no okay I just made it up bye
you know what I mean it's
the dudes on here are just not helpful
they're not helpful like I know he's at
work and he just doesn't want to hear
him but you know so um Jamie at this
point is still trying to convince
herself that she's imagining it
so then another time like I guess
shortly afterward she's down in the
basement in the creepy basement because
of course you always have to do laundry
down in the creepy basement in these
houses
um you know what I mean which is weird
our house doesn't have a basement but
our laundry room is not creepy it's just
in the front of the house by the by the
garage
um not creepy in the least so she's down
in the creepy basement doing laundry and
she has like a baby monitor down there
so she can watch the kids like while
they're sleeping
and in the baby monitor it looks like
the nursery or the kid's room is on fire
she doesn't see any fire but she sees
like a whole bunch of smoke you know
what I mean and she obviously like
freaks out as you would and runs up
there like holy [__] like the kid's room
is on fire and there's nothing up there
no smoke no smell of fire no nothing and
she's like what the [__] was that all
about
so she calls Aaron or she you know when
Aaron comes home she's like look I saw
smoke in the room like the room is on
fire and then I came up and there's
nothing there and then Aaron said well
maybe the camera is malfunctioning like
you know maybe you just saw it was you
know an anomaly and things she's like
look dude it was smoke all right so
she's like Anyway the kids are sleeping
in our room because I'm not you know I
don't trust this [__] you know what I
mean and then like while they're
sleeping while the kids are sleeping in
the parents room the baby Lacey was just
like cries all night and they said she
kept looking scared or like looking at
something like something was in there
that she was looking at and they were
like freaking out
then a little while after this uh Jamie
is sleeping Aaron's at work again like
in the middle of the night and she was
she heard
what sounded like a girl laughing or
like giggling and she said it sounded
like it was only in the same room like
two or three feet away from her
and she said she just laid there and
listened to it like freaking out for a
while and then finally she got up the
nerves to kind of like sit up and look
and obviously there was nothing there
now on the show
the the reenactment they actually showed
like a little ghost girl like standing
there like laughing and stuff like that
she didn't say she saw anybody she just
said she heard a girl laughing only two
two or three feet away and there was
nothing there
so when Aaron gets home at like Dawn or
whatever
um the mom and the kids are all sleeping
in the living room because she just
noped right the [__] out of the bedroom
and you can't really blame her I mean to
be honest
so he decides he's gonna sit up with him
too so he's kind of sitting there in a
chair kind of watching over him and
dozing and then this part was really
creepy too I really liked this part
um he started here he finally finally
hears something because you know it
takes like forever like until until the
dude actually and he's like oh I guess
my wife's not crazy after all
so um he started hearing
three piano notes repeated over and over
creepy [__] it was super creepy and in
in the episode it's [__] creepy
it's dark and he's sucking inside the
house and he's just listening to hear
ding ding
yeah like an old piano or like a toy
piano yeah it's like a little old toy
piano and he's searching the house
trying to figure out where that's coming
from
and you can't find it and I was even
freaked out when he like when the actor
like comes on and he's like I can't
figure out where it's coming from like
the way he said it like freaking yeah he
wakes the wife up wouldn't she asleep
yeah and she's like what are you doing
he's like and he's like you hear it hear
it he goes yeah I hear it he goes good
because you know they think he says good
he's like I can't I'm trying to fit and
I can't figure out where it is because
it sounds like an old piano
and they couldn't find where it was
coming from d D yeah it just kept doing
that over and over and over and then
um she said it sounded like it was in
the next Ram so yeah and I was like man
that's like something a poltergeist
would do
you know Mammoth Mountain would do [__]
like that but
not not exactly that but that's like
something it would have done
kind of creepy sounded plausible to me
and then they then they go to the actual
Witness
and uh he to me he was credible
just kind of a good old boy and he's
like I know y'all don't believe it but
you got to keep an open mind that's what
I heard you know
and now
I wasn't there he said it sounded like
it was in the Next Room but you every
room you went to you couldn't find it I
mean maybe it was far away outside the
house
yeah because on the reenactment the
first thing he did was like go to the
door and like look out the door like I'm
assuming he thought maybe it was coming
from outside yeah but it wasn't
evidently he was
it was coming from inside the house but
he couldn't find where and they didn't
have anything like that in the house
evidently well she said the weird thing
she said we used to have a piano in the
house when we first moved in but I'm
they didn't have it anymore yeah Phantom
noise
so that's not something that your normal
civilian would just make up
you'd have to think about that
and I think if you thought about it
you'd come up with something different
it was just it sounds like something
that happened like I said little subtle
[__] like that is way scarier to me yeah
then you know what I mean weird [__]
because it because it's easy to sit back
and go yeah I was there and all of a
sudden I saw it it looked like the Grim
Reaper in its face and it's right
they came at me and it almost got me
well [__] everybody says that [__] not
scary but this [__] man I never could
hear find out where that pianos it was
like on that other case
where he wakes up he's kind of
undergoing possession he wakes up he's
at his mom's house and they hear the
organ music and they never could figure
out where it was coming from yeah that's
right see that creeps me out so your mom
goes in do you have the radio on I said
no I don't know where that's he's like
what the [__] is that [__] hearing this
organ music and his mom then they
couldn't figure the source and his mom's
like she thought maybe it was the spirit
of her dead mother yeah and I guess it
went away in this they never really said
how long they heard the piano for was it
at least minutes
and they never really said how it ended
did it fade away or did it just stop
yeah they didn't say they didn't say
they didn't say
which I thought I would have asked how
did it end
did it just fade away off into the
distance or did it just abruptly stop
doing it
but they never they never said
that's the thing about these you can't
question these episodes
and you don't know what was edited out
yeah maybe they said other [__] and they
edited that out because they didn't like
what they said but it might have been
important
you know maybe it was well we're
interested in all these little details
yeah you know what I mean it's like you
know if you're gonna say it's like I
woke up and I heard this like this
creepy three notes like repeating over
and over we want to know like all of the
ins and outs of that yeah they might
have edited something out because they
thought it would make the case
Incredible or you know or it might
undermine the case but to somebody who's
seen [__] like this before maybe it
actually would have strengthened the
case in my opinion you know they're like
oh we're not gonna tell them that they
won't but never believe you you know
that kind of [__] no women hold on what
what happened and then maybe you hear
their story you're like oh yeah yeah
you're full of [__] you don't know no
you just don't know what was taken out
and then what was added visually
images and [__] nobody described that
that's just the image that they showed
you well I was gonna say too that it's
like now the dude did say well while he
was
um like hearing the piano thing he heard
the girl giggling too because he also
heard that and like I said so they would
put in the reenactment they showed like
the ghost of the girl like laughing but
nobody said that they saw saw the ghost
the ghost so there's nobody said they
saw that so there's discarded
but they didn't say this yeah so there's
deception in these episodes maybe it's
not malicious deception it's just
they're trying to make it they're trying
to make it spice it up so I'm gonna show
you what they believed that they heard
or saw or what was really happening the
little girl goes but he didn't they're
just horrifically he didn't see it right
yeah he never said he saw it right but
he didn't say he heard it heard laughing
like a girl laughing
um
yeah so like I said he's looking all
over the house we're inside the basement
everything like that
um now later I guess uh Jamie fell back
to sleep at some point and then she woke
up again and then they both heard
I can't really describe this noise
but they and they didn't really
articulate it very well either the way
they did it on the um reenactment was it
kind of sounded like a bunch of voices
like muffled screaming or moaning or
something like that oh later yeah right
you know I just said it was a muffled
voice and muffled sound
but then what they sh what they let you
hear through the Epic through the
episode didn't sound like anything to me
other than some kind of a crescendo
like a storm type of deal maybe there
were voices in it I don't know it
sounded like voices to me but it kind of
sounded like you know like in a horror
movie where they're trying to be like oh
my God we opened up Hell's Gate yeah
like it kind of said like all the
tormented Souls down there like it
sounded like that but like a more
low-key version of that yeah like a
muffled version it kind of sounded like
that yeah yeah they did say it sounded
muffled but they didn't say exactly what
it said what it was they did I think
they did say voices at some point
but I mean because I did write that down
but so I think they did say it was
muffled voices but the way that I mean
it was creepy like on the show but I
don't know exactly what they heard yeah
so Jamie starts doing uh research to see
if you know she can find somebody to
help them or whatever
um but turns out that Aaron actually
hears this paranormal expert
um dude like who just wrote a book and
he was like talking on a radio show that
he was listening to like at work or
whatever
and according to this expert I don't
think they mentioned who it was or if
they did I didn't write it down
um
basically one of the things that you
were supposed to do like to help you get
rid of the Paranormal Activity was you
had to just like face it or just like
face your fear you know what I mean so
um basically what so what Jamie decides
to do is that Gable
the ghost or whatever
is hanging out with Mason and keeping
Mason awake I guess because they're like
why is this three-year-old kid like
still awake and he's like Gable wants to
play you know what I mean so Mom is
basically like well you I'm gonna tell
Gable right now that he needs to get the
[__] out you know so it's that kind of
thing so she was kind of like dropping
her nuts on The Ghost and they thought
that that would maybe help and actually
it did help for a little while because
they said after she told Gable to like
get the [__] out because Mason had to
sleep and it's like no he can't play
right now and you get out of here or
whatever
um and then they said after that the
house was actually kind of quiet for the
next you know two three weeks or
whatever
but then as usual like [__] comes back
so then she was in the laundry room
again in the creepy basement and she
said that she felt somebody
stepping on the back of her pant leg I
think is what she said like so when
obviously no one's there so like an
invisible person is like stepping on the
back of her pant leg and then she like
turns around like what the [__] and then
something grabbed the back of her calf
she said she felt like something grabbed
her leg
so she like wigs the [__] out like I
said probably as you would and calls her
husband at work said he was she was
hysterical
um and he leaves work immediately you
know fair play to him and he basically
as soon as he gets home he like runs
down to the basement and just starts
yelling at The Ghost and this was
actually the um the scene that they used
like for the Flash Forward because you
know how they always do that like
starting in season five so um so he's
just like down there yo it's like show
yourselves and you know what why don't
you come out and if you want me to
believe in you in bloody blast so he's
like yelling at them to come out but the
ghosts are
um suddenly shy and they're just like
nope we're not doing that just or they
think it's funny to just you know knock
him out
so then their friend Pam uh actually
ends up calling some paranormal
investigators like a little two-person
team or whatever
and they say that what they think
happened
was that
um probably the ghosts essentially like
hitchhiked back to the house with them
like from the cemetery because they said
yeah we used to take the kids to the
cemetery and walk around and then Mason
started like we should that's like the
Haunted Mansion with the dude we'll see
that's what I was thinking that I was
thinking that yeah
with the little ghost like sitting on
your head and [__] like that that's
exactly what I thought of when they said
that
it's just like the Haunted Mansion
you're taking the ghost on with you but
uh but yeah so they said that's probably
what happened like it's you went there
and like some of the ghosts were like
Hey we're latching out of these people
we're gonna go hang out at their house
for a little while maybe they have some
good snacks or whatever you know I don't
know what kind of snacks goes like
though blueberry I guess so um they said
that uh so they do like all the they
have all the ghost hunting gadgets and
whatnot
and they said that there was like a
really high uh like Spike's of
electromagnetic energy and all of that
so they try to like communicate via EVP
so they what they did was they didn't do
the normal thing where they have just
like the little regular audio tape
recorder and they just like ask
questions and [__] they did they
videotaped the whole thing you know what
I mean but the thing about it they kind
of went a lot into yeah we're doing this
EVP session but I don't think they came
up with any EVPs did they like they
didn't really say anything I remember
mentioning yeah I don't think they
mentioned like nobody was on there going
live or like you know playing piano
which kind of led to some credibility
yeah maybe
because
um if it was a a fake investigation they
bring in EVP stuff because oh yeah we
got EVPs look at the [__] we got it's
saying all kind of crazy [__] down here
you know yeah but oh it's a [__]
portal Portal's open there's millions of
ghosts
you got all kind of this place is
[__] lousy all coming out the portal
the thing about the portals and the
millions of ghosts and families of
ghosts is that
that opens up a
fall a fake investigator to make any
claims
this particular EVP sounds like
something so we can get it to fit this
other ghost and another one sounds like
something else so we can get that to fit
to this other ghost over here
thereby eliminating the need for any
kind of cohesive narrative
it's just oh it's just random ghosts
yeah yeah talking it's like [__]
Grand Central Station here it's like
ghost Grand Central Station I don't
believe in Portals
no matter no
we talked about portals like on the cup
because we had a show before where they
said oh your housing there's a portal
yeah [__] you hit the portal in here
because we were talking about how the
ghosts are just like hanging out on the
other side just waiting for somebody to
open it yeah they all like poor
that's just hilarious if you've ever had
an out-of-body experience or a
near-death experience in nde which I've
had both and a [__] Obe
when you exteriorize and you end up in
that [__] what they call the spirit
realm or whatever it's a wide or wide
open empty space there's nothing over
there
unless you ask to see it you got to know
the address
but it's just um
if there was a portal there'd be nothing
on the other side
nothing special
yeah like I said it was they would have
to know about the portal I'm sure ghosts
would have better things yeah just like
all hang out there waiting for this like
like I said like waiting for the
elevator door to open you know what I
mean yeah from when I saw it get off
from what I saw it's kind of sleepy over
there it's like being underwater in the
ocean
[__] swims by but it's far away
just like that so yeah so they're doing
this EVP session oh okay so what it was
they didn't get the EVPs per se as in
you know you didn't hear it when you
were doing the session but then later on
when you listen to recording but they
said that when they were doing it
because it was um the two paranormal
investigators one of whose name was also
Pam they always had a friend named Pam
so that's confusing and the other one's
name was Ashley so Pam and Ashley are
there and then Jamie the mom is also
there so they're doing it and um they
said they felt like a real heavy energy
in the room and then I don't know if the
video was actually glitching out or if
they just did that like for the show
purposes because they showed like the
video tape like glitching out but they
did say that all of them heard like
whispering and giggling and they said
and we heard that with our ears it
wasn't just like like an EVP where you
go back and listen to it and hear it
then they said we actually heard it but
I don't know if it recorded they didn't
mention that so I'm imagining now
um
they also said that
the mirror I guess they were doing this
in the kids room because that's where
the weird [__] was happening they said
that they felt like there was a bubble
forming on the front of the mirror with
like an entity coming out they didn't
say they saw that they just said that it
felt like that or the psychic was saying
it felt like that
so they're like so the mirror did they
say the mirror was a portal they did
kind of didn't they uh or that that was
how through that's how the ghost was
coming through the end of the world was
yeah because they did say mirrors could
be portals or portal like things so yeah
so they're like okay well the guy's
coming through the mirror so we need to
do something about that
so Ashley does a cleansing on the mirror
using essentially like lemon water so I
was like so just regular cleaning of the
mirror just regular [__] that you're
cleaning the mirror
will Windex work
to keep ghosts real good if you clean
the mirror with Windex will that keep
the ghost from I don't know or does it
have to be like an organic yeah
cleaning product and then that'll keep
well that's good because that keeps your
mirror clean and it keeps Spirits from
coming through the portal I don't buy
any of that [__] no I don't either I
just that's why I'm making a joke no the
only only reason why is something like
that might work is this if you believed
it worked maybe you're what you might
for one of a better word psychic energy
which I'm not sure if that totally
describes it your psychic energy might
force it to to be real
maybe yeah
the act itself of putting sage and some
[__] or some lemon juice that now
you might as well just put holy water on
it and that's all notional
well which would boil down to will yeah
will power they kind of skirted around
that I feel like because
I think they never come out and say this
out right really but they do kind of
skirt around the issue of you can use
whatever you want as long as you believe
that it will work probably true you know
what I mean right kind of like in
Salem's a lot when [__]
that vampire [__] comes through the
window and [__] challenges that
priest and have a battle battle of will
you remember they pointed puts the
[__] cross in front in front of the
[__] what's his name Barlow Mr Barlow
yeah and there was like a battle of
[__] faith and the priest didn't have
faith in Barlow [__] tore his [__] up
like because he didn't believe in it
they did that in fright night as well
yeah the original Fright Night yeah like
the like actually the cross wouldn't
work unless you actually believed that
it would work yeah like if you just held
a cross up and you were an atheist or
whatever
you know what I mean but if you actually
believed it so it's not so much the
cross it's your will right your faith
now you're [__] like dropping your
psychic nuts you know what I mean like I
ain't letting this [__] happen
which I would that's more plausible
because it would be a battle of psychic
will of course right what they're
talking about yeah yeah so it doesn't
matter like what doesn't matter what it
is because you believe it things that
you use as long as so we laugh about it
being like lemon water and seeds and
stuff like that but it could be anything
yeah if as long as you believed in it
well all religions do this [__]
Taoist priests do stuff like exorcisms
uh Christians Muslims I don't know if
the Jews do it they probably do
um but it all boils down to the faith in
their interpretation of their religion
so
but that would boil down to Will
power
and Faith so maybe psychic you're
psychic
Force you know
maybe murder Hornet said I love fright
night I do too I love fast oh great
movie I love Friday night yeah it's one
of my favorite movies of the 80s one of
my favorite horror comedies for sure
it's hard to talk I've seen it a million
times hard to top those old movies
they were [__] well a couple years
ago for Halloween I dressed up as
vampire Amy
from Fright Night I still have the red
curly wig and everything yeah I did like
the big mouth and how the white dress
and all that
was super and I had the contact lens to
see what happened to those I guess they
still got them somewhere they were
yellow
um yeah so so they do the lemon water
cleansing on the mirror to keep the
ghosts from popping through there
because you know how that goes you know
what goes popping through your mirror
all the time
um and then they also do the sage thing
too just for safety purposes
um and we kind of laughed because the
whole Sage thing it's like yeah you
start in the middle of the room and then
like you move toward the outset because
you're like pushing yeah you're pushing
it goes down and then you said they be
sure to leave a door window cracked I
said yeah so the ghost could go out and
go to the neighbor's house is that what
it is because it I don't know what
what's funny laugh so much you have a
ghost that can pass through [__]
physical objects like walls and stuff
but yeah you better leave a door open
like leave a door before like I said
it's all just no notional it's just kind
of like it doesn't make any sense
logically when you think about it
because like you said yeah ghosts can
like pop in and out of existence it can
go through walls they can do all the
stuff but then suddenly it's like oh
they can't get out if you have all the
doors and windows closed like they're
locked in that's that's very silly an
exteriorized person that's having it out
of body experience can move forward and
backwards in time
go back and see the past
can go through physical dimensions and
then Dimensions that were never physical
so a ghost would be like that
it wouldn't matter if the door was open
and I always wondered too it's like they
always showed them in movies like going
through the walls I'm like why don't
they ever go through the floor oh they
probably would
they never show that though do they
because like the ghost is trying to go
like that it's like oh [__] Poltergeist
was taking objects from downstairs and
moving them upstairs without going
through the stairwell
things appearing inside a closed room
you were in that room the door was
closed and things would appear in their
small objects and they were from
downstairs the door never opened
so they somehow enter penetrated the
matter
or they teleported but that's a
violation of physics as we know it so
physics is not of out as we see it
it's an illusion
they're also talking about uh Knight of
the Demons was classic too yeah that's
right that's awesome sounds familiar
like I saw that that's another [__]
reason I think I saw that one yeah
murder where it said Linnea Quigley
yeah and you know what still hot
she still looks I mean I haven't seen
her in a while but she yeah last I saw
her it might have been 10 years ago but
she's still hot yeah
uh oh what's her name stuck and still
hot the one from [__] uh free
animator what's that what was her name
Barbara Barbara Crampton hot as [__]
she's still in horror movies she's in
lots of stuff yeah
and of course uh Cassandra Peterson
yeah that's the hottest old lady ever
see all the all the horrors they just
they stay hot like yeah you guys know
where is Elvira she's like 73 she's
still smoking hot
she looks exactly the same yeah I just
saw her like a few months ago on the Joe
Bob Halloween special like sure she did
her own special like on shutter and I
was like holy [__] she looks exactly the
[__] thing she's had some work done
well obviously me too obviously but she
doesn't look any different hormone
therapies and staying in shape and uh I
guess positive attitude and having fun I
you know she she was never forgotten
like vampire was Mila nermy she was
forgotten and she [__] rotted away
because they didn't have [__] um in
mayla's day they didn't have [__]
conventions yeah
if they had Horicon and [__] like that
mailer would have done real good real
well at conventions yeah you know she'd
made a lot of money got a lot of
attention and kept her spirits up
I've said before I kind of feel like the
horror fandom yeah is probably one of
the best fandoms in the sense that they
remember you man and and if they love
you they [__] love you and they will
just like support every [__] thing
you do the actress that played Jason's
mom
yeah in the first Friday the 13th was a
[__] well-known High Caliber actress
yeah mainstream all her mainstream fans
forgot about her only the [__] horror
Community remembered everybody knows who
she is like all the horror nerds and she
made a living going to conventions yeah
as an old lady yeah and [__]
everybody still loved her that [__]
probably extended her life
by a decade probably
at least
like I said and she said I never
realized I would be remembered for that
movie right because I think what she was
doing is she didn't want to do it and
she was like she thought it was going to
be some throwaway piece of [__] yeah and
it's like who know you know who knew
that like you know [__] 40 50 years
later she's making a living off of that
movie not the other High Caliber movies
that she made those fans were long dead
I'm telling you that's horror fans and
like I said horror fans are really and
they like old [__] too so it's like even
if you were in a movie he's like way
back in the 50s and 60s they'll still
remember you and come see you you know
what I mean yeah
the dude who didn't turn right
who did not do a right face in the end
of a new hope
he's he does
you see the crowd of the [__] Rebel
soldiers when they turn to face [__]
Princess Leia's the formation one dude
doesn't turn yeah and that dude actually
was selling them
oh you're the dude that didn't turn yeah
yeah yeah yeah and they all know 20
bucks yeah all right yeah [__]
hilarious it is hilarious but now the
horror the horror scene
they stick by you they do like I said
I've you know I'm not it's not like I
have a huge amount of experience with
other fandoms but I do kind of feel like
I feel like horror fandom is less toxic
maybe than other fandoms
um yeah I'm not saying that there's not
like infighting and stuff because there
is but it doesn't seem as bad and I
don't know horror fans just seem like
they just seem generally like nicer
people which you wouldn't think because
people would be like oh you watch all
this like [__] up [__] but honestly
like most people I'd known that have
been super into horror movies are like
the nicest people ever yeah the nicest
people ever I don't know why that is but
because you get all your bad [__] out
like just watching horror movies we me
and Jen we don't really have
um guests on the show anymore but we've
considered doing some guess we can get
them we have enough people where we can
get guests
if we would ever have a guest on the
show it'd be Jeffrey Combs I want
Jeffrey Combs on this house and he I
could probably either that or Crustle
I could get crossed I wonder if Crystal
would be on this side yeah yeah
probably would let's get him on here in
a sandwich for like a crisp for like a
Christmas special yeah but I want to get
Jeffrey Combs on the show to talk about
schran from [__] I want to talk about
shrad from [__] Star Trek Enterprise
and he loves that character he his
fantasy was to make a full-length Motion
Picture based on a strand
and [__] shran he was an endorian
[__] Captain a blue dude with the
antennas
he was the [__] endorian Captain Kirk
he would have made a [__] great
leading character
but it would be an alien ship with an
alien crew doing cool [__]
his Macho little ass
you [__] good I love shran
he was a good character I'll watch
anything Jeffrey Combs yeah he's like
well I mean and like I said a lot of
horror fan of her like that too like man
Jeffrey Combs Bruce Campbell like
anything those [__] are in yeah
we're gonna watch that and then Deep
Space Nine Combs did a great [__] gem
had our guy he was a clone every time he
get killed he'd come back because
they're cloned thousands of millions of
them yeah that's what the world needs
more Jeffrey comes yeah yeah
Jeffrey Combs
that sounds nice doesn't it
I like that idea and I've watched
columns on other shows he drinks on the
show he says hold on I gotta take a leak
so he likes to fit right in he likes to
drink on the show he did be just it'd be
just like this he'd fit right in yeah we
have him on a side traction yeah he
sounds like you'd be like a lot we
talking about it we'll do a comb show we
had to contact him maybe we should and
we'll do a Jeffrey Combs special
yeah that [__] run three or four hours
as long as he wants to go
we talk about what he wants to talk
about we're talking about shran
so I'm going to talk about sharan yeah
whether you want peer pressure yeah he
likes that character though like I said
he likes to talk about it yeah he likes
sharan
um but yeah okay so where was I oh okay
so they were doing the sage thing and
then like I said we laughed about them
having a window cracked and stuff like
that so the ghost could get out
um they also did this other thing which
I don't think I've seen another haunting
episode where they did specifically this
I've seen ones where they did uh like
salt rings and [__] like that because
you know yeah salt is like a big you
know paranormal thing like to keep
ghosts away or whatever but this one
they said oh this is kind of like a
southern thing I'm like okay I never
heard of it but whatever I'm from the
South but
where they have like salt but they flick
it and I'm like all right so so they're
basically just like flicking it and the
thing about it is that what they're
trying to do because she explained it
it's like sympathetic magic essentially
so they're like the salt is from an
outgoing tide I don't know like I guess
she gathered the salt herself or bought
it from somebody that said that it was
from I just you know I don't know how
you can tell but whatever but they said
the whole principle of it is that
because like an outgoing tide it's
supposed to like it's like a baptism it
sort of like pulling away like your sins
or the negative energy or whatever so
it's like she was talking about that so
basically they have salt and they're
just like kind of flicking it everywhere
so they're kind of kind of covering all
the bases you know what I mean although
I don't think they they didn't call a
priest on this one though which again is
unusual usually that's one of the
Avenues that they take but they didn't
do it on this one
so yeah so they do the salt they do the
sage they do the lemon they do all of
that stuff
um but it doesn't really seem to work uh
at this point they're kind of taking
pictures around the house and they
notice that there's like this big spike
on the EMF meter and then the three
pictures because the the lady the
Paranormal Investigator she's like oh I
always take like three pictures like Bam
Bam Bam like that like in sets and so
she's like this one set that they had
where the spike uh where the EMF spiked
was she said the first picture was
normal and then the second picture had
like this dark figure like it was
walking across the picture and then the
third picture was normal again so it was
almost like something like passed
through the [__] like right when this
bike was so they thought that was like
pretty creepy
so at this point they're like okay well
maybe we need to find out like who these
ghosts are so they go to the graveyard
that's right by the house and they find
this Tombstone now see okay I don't know
how big this Cemetery was they didn't
really say but they did find a tombstone
for a guy named Gabriel Jackson and
they're like oh well maybe this is who
the kid is talking about because he
keeps saying Gable and maybe he's like a
little kid and he can't say Gabriel I
was like well I don't know that's a
reach and and another thing too is that
Gabriel isn't a very uncommon name so
it's like that was the only Gabriel in
the cemetery how big is the cemetery I
find that hard to believe and I kind of
feel like that was kind of like even a
more common name back in the time period
when this Cemetery was from but this guy
Gabriel Jackson that was buried in the
cemetery had been killed in the Civil
War and so because
I don't know see that's the thing I
don't know if anybody saw him
other than the little kid
um so the fact that they showed in the
reenactment that he had a civil war
uniform on I think they only did that
because of this you know what I'm saying
because nobody said like the mom or the
dad they said oh we saw a dude like in a
[__] Civil War uniform and oh this is
who the guy is you know what I mean I
don't know it just feels like there's a
lot of stuff that was kind of left out
um so they're like okay well maybe this
is who it is well hi pookie what are you
trying to get your attention she's
trying to climb up in the Show Mommy
oh yeah
um but yeah so they're like well what
about this little girl that we've heard
like laughing in the house like I said
they haven't seen her I don't think but
they heard her laughing in the house and
then they said they did a little
research in the neighborhood I don't
know if this is true or not but they
said supposedly
um there was a little girl who was um
the daughter of a slave and she had
drowned like in a lake that used to be
on this property like where the house
was or where the cemetery was like I
said it was all kind of part of One
Plantation or one thing so I don't know
if that's true but they said so maybe
that's who the little girl was like this
little drown girl
so basically uh the investigators then
tell Jamie now they've done all this
stuff it's like she just do a prayer
to complete the blessing because
obviously the ghosts are still here
um and she's like well what kind of
prayer and she's like anything that you
actually believe in it doesn't actually
matter like what the prayer is but as
long as just as long as you believe in
it then it doesn't matter what it is so
she basically just does the standard you
know uh what do you what do you call
that [__]
the I don't know I don't know what I
don't remember what that what that
prayer is called it has a name but I
can't like think of it Lord's Prayer
yeah yeah that's what that's what it was
either way I walked through the shower
yeah yeah yeah I think that's what it
was yeah so she starts doing that
and um they you know like they usually
do when they're doing X they didn't do
an exorcism in this but whenever they're
doing prayers or exorcisms like when
it's the big climax like they're getting
rid of the ghosts or whatever
um then they'll try to like this one
they do like flashing lights and
everyone looks at their ex pained
Expressions you know what I mean like oh
[__] like this is so painful and then
like they're doing flashbacks of like
all the scary [__] that they already
showed in the show and there was that
kind of stuff
um and then so all that happens and then
like when she's done with the prayer
like it's all like
and then she turns to the paranormal
investigators and she says they're gone
aren't they like she knew and I was like
wow that was easy so all you needed was
some lemon juice and some sage and
some prayer and some inflict some salt
and
Bob's your uncle you just got rid of the
[__] that's a British thing
well I know we have some British people
in the uh in the in the crowd so I
thought that they would think that was
funny that I said that but um yeah so
basically the paranormal investigators
are like well you can you didn't need us
you can stop it yourself like as long as
you believe that you can like as long as
you have faith and as long as you you
know or she's like you're the master of
your own house just like don't don't
they basically don't let the ghosts walk
all over you I think was the implication
there so uh so yeah so the guy you know
the the narrator is like oh the
Paranormal nightmare is over
and then after that like is a little
Coda they said they actually talked to
some of the neighbors like people that
lived around the neighborhood and they
implied they didn't really go into this
but they implied maybe that they had had
some Paranormal Activity as well because
of the proximity of the cemetery uh that
was the suggestion that they were
putting across anyway that other that I
guess like other people go walk through
the cemetery and the ghosts are like hey
let's follow this one home and [__] with
them for a little while like what you
know I guess the ghosts don't have
anything better to do they're just
hanging out in the cemetery and they get
bored and yeah you just happen to walk
past and they just like latch onto your
ass and go to your house and like I said
raise your fridge and I don't drink your
beer I don't know I don't know what
ghosts do when they get to your house
[Laughter]
um let's see uh goes past real life
murder Hornets that I know a lot of Star
Trek fans that would show up for that
like if we had Jeffrey comes on yeah he
was also talking about that what do you
say some of the fan films are real good
yeah yeah the best fan material is on
YouTube for free Star Trek Continues
It's the final season to the old
original
series with Kirk and Spock and
everything and it
it connects
this the television series to a Star
Trek Motion Picture yeah and that's real
Star Trek a lot of the guys that were on
the original series the descendants of
the people that were on the original
series are
are on it
a lot of the same writing
Aaron Gray's in it [__] um she shows
up Lou Ferrigno shows up in it
um the dude who played [__]
um
that Greek god he's from the original
series he shows up as that Greek god
again [__] um yeah that that's real
Star Trek second part of the mirror
Series where [__]
uh um Kirk ends up on the mirror and
meets that Spock
part two of that's on it called you know
uh that that's a great series they made
him stop it CBS made him stop
even though it complied with
fan base [__] but it was so good they
were like nah this is a real show you
guys can't do that
well they don't I mean they let them put
it on YouTube but they can't they're not
allowed to like charge money yeah they
don't but also they said that they
weren't allowed to make any more yeah
so
sucks
because uh Vic Vic mignona was the guy
that was behind a lot of that Todd
haberkorn and who played
played Spock they wanted to do
a bunch of stuff a bunch of like movie
type things that were to take place
in between Star Trek the motion picture
and wrathicon they said there's a lot of
time there that they could have covered
that had been [__] great
that have been great
they even did promo shots of them in the
wrathicon style uniforms
yeah but it is it really is a good
series
Hugo said are you guys planning on
reviewing the Pope's Exorcist
maybe I mean we might get around you
haven't seen it yet like I said we
haven't seen it there's like a ton of
movies that I need to see
um we still need to see I still want to
see Renfield I want to see
Evil Dead rise we were just talking to
Oscar yeah before the show and he said
oh we need to see that because it was
any movie we receive on Blu-ray in a
physical location here at this place if
you send us a Blu-ray we will review
that movie
yeah I mean the ones that people send us
are always like top priority top
priority so like the next one that we
have to do because xanada also sent us
the professionals so that's gonna be the
next one that we're gonna do and um like
I said we never it's weird because we
never did a review of terrifyer too even
though we did watch it yeah because that
was actually but we had to move Amazon
we had to move DVDs to the front yeah
and uh you know [__] uh my boy Louie
Louie Hernandez [__] sent me the best
movies I've seen all right and during
the move we kind of lost track we
finally caught up with a breakfast club
I think that's the only I think that's
the only one that he said they haven't
done yeah
Louie's got fantastic taste in movies if
he sends it to me I'm like okay
well he's like he's got you pegged like
he's got me exactly better without this
[__] packing [__] go ahead see these
women always [__] talking about but
hey that was your dirty mind way to that
place I'm getting [__] self-conscious
Jenny wants to Peg me I'm trying to
[__] complex about it what if all the
what if I get what if all all of you
guys like get enough money at like no
Jenny's trying to [__] get me [__]
in the booty all right she's trying to
make money man stop that [__]
she's talking about stream mate our
stream mate effort and we shot some porn
the other day I had the [__] camera
all [__] up man my hair's cut up the
whole thing's useless
the whole thing's used I mean there
might be a little bit eclipses
close up still well the Stills were good
from it
um yeah at the very end of it is good we
can use it for other things we can use
it for [__] promo shots and [__]
everything is progress forward but man
it's hard to shoot porn
yeah yeah
you gotta we're learning though it's
best if the camera's in hand you want to
Ashton cam well that's what I mean it's
they always say this like if you know
anything about it but um you know it's
like oh well there's nothing like it
particularly sexy or no anything about
like shooting porn yeah and it's like
what they say that but when you do it
you're just like oh yeah I see what
they're talking about yeah you're
worried about so many other [__]
things it's a production like it's fun
yeah I'm not saying it's not fun but it
is it's not like normal sex no no no
like there's a million different factors
you have to take into consideration you
have to keep stopping in the middle and
like yeah moving around and like moving
this over here [__] changes like this
isn't gonna work with that [__]
outfit Ray and then like yeah or like
that sex toy isn't working out right
this [__] here so we're constantly
it's like extended foreplay you're
aroused during it but it's hard for
[__] any
for any kind of like
you're not really satisfied well you
can't really like just let go and get
into it because you're too worried about
like does this look stupid on camera or
is it you know what I mean it might be
wasting my effort with this I mean how's
the camera angle it's just
which you think is crazy you know I'm
I'm actually a trained actors those
grampers if he's in there we went to
[__] after school together [__]
well High School level at school but our
[__] was really good we had a really
good [__] teacher Marilyn rice cub
who's off of 24 big Superstar is my
ex-girlfriend
and uh she came out of that same [__]
trauma program I guarantee you she
learned more from [__] Julia
Salisbury than she learned from in
University from that Julia Salisbury and
grandpas can attest
and he's he's a cop friend of mine who's
coming uh she was a [__] great Drama
teacher
great Drama teacher
I was into the method acting and [__]
so you just like acted like you become
an [__] do you become he's acting
like an [__] yeah yeah so you're
still method acting now no after all of
these years you become that character
and you Channel it yeah I know and it
takes all the pressure off of you
you know yeah I was doing leads and then
later on after that you know when it's
going to Brazil I was doing stuff doing
commercials and it's the same thing it
takes pressure off of you when you're
method acting because you're no you're
not you anymore right
so that's why a lot of actors do it
although like I said some there's kind
of stories about actors that are really
into doing that and how difficult they
are to work with because yeah it makes
you crazy yeah because you can't
yeah interact with them like a normal
person like when they're when you're not
shooting because they're still acting
they're still in there that character
they're in that mode which makes me
understand Marlon Brando I got a lot of
respect and understanding of Marlon
Brandon Marla was [__] crazy he was a
method actor and did a lot of [__]
drugs too well yeah I'm sure that but
yeah I'd have gotten along with Marlon
but see pretending to be someone trying
to kiss me though that [__] that [__]
oh he'd kiss a [__] in a
heartbeat you had to watch him
on the lips
was he the one that was it was Marla
Brando from Last Tango in Paris right
with the with the with the stick of
butter up the butt yeah I think I think
they was yeah that was him yeah so he
might try to put a sticker but you never
know he never can't he was trisexual he
just tried out on you
John Gora said some actors kind of lose
themselves in the roles like Mickey
Rourke yeah yeah oh speaking of Mickey
Rourke that's another movie that you
need to see Thomas and this is my
recommendation I'm sure other people
have recommended it it's a Darren
Aronofsky movie okay I loved her and it
has Mickey Rourke in it it's called The
Wrestler okay yeah I haven't seen it and
uranusky I like him great yeah I look
great yeah I love Noah I thought that
was a [__] at badass science fiction
movie yeah and you still haven't seen
Requiem for a Dream no I haven't seen it
woo that's a downer it's a downer all
right the wrestler is kind of a downer
too I'm not gonna lie but it's great
Requiem For Dream is great yeah but holy
[__] you got to really be in the mood
for her
what's his name Anthony Hopkins
which one the Welsh actor yeah the guy
who did [__] um Hannibal actor
Hannibal electric yeah yeah [__]
Anthony Hopkins yeah I don't know if
he's a method actor but I detect that he
is a method actor oh I don't know if he
is like a sets mental I know some of
them are like I know that um somebody
like Daniel Day-Lewis I know that he's
like really well known for like me yeah
I'll respect him everything I've seen
about him and and I remember seeing an
interview with him and he's like he's
saying I hate movies he says I hate
[__] Hollywood movies I hate he says
I want to be
on the stage in community theater and I
was like yeah because that's kind of
where I came from a lot of actors
because it's just instant gratification
right
I still kind of get this a little bit
through YouTube with the comment section
but it's better if you see people
you could play off the crowd a lot
better
and it just it feels good which is why
Maryland went into Comet comics
being a comedian
because it's instant gratification you
know if you've done well or not you can
read it on the
expressions of the crowd
yeah because you know I still talk to
her yeah she still [__] loves it
but she likes being a comic more than
she liked to be in a television actress
well like I said any like shooting TV
and movies and stuff like that it just
to me it seems like artificial well and
it seems like tedious yeah because you
have you know you have to Let's a lot of
it's just waiting around you're waiting
around for them to set up the lights and
set up the thing and do the makeup and
then then when you do it it's like you
have to shoot like the same thing like
over and over and from different angles
and it's like you know it's many takes
and so it's just I just feel like it
would be really tedious yeah you know
what I mean yeah and it's knowing how it
works it's just kind of like I'm amazed
that any movies or TV come out good yeah
you know what I try
but the fact that so many of them come
out good I'm like that's amazing to me
uh Zach asked if you had seen Black Swan
did you see Black Swan yeah that was the
one with what's her name the little girl
the uh I call her a little girl she's my
professional uh Natalie Portman Natalie
Portman right yeah yeah we saw I really
like Black Swan I have it I remember we
have it on Blu-ray no DVD yeah yeah I
bought it on deep it was like in the in
the Bargain Bin so I picked it up I
remember it being okay but it did make a
big impression on me I don't remember
anything about it yeah I really liked it
I've seen it a couple times I really
liked it although she's done good [__]
good [__] and bad [__] some of it's just
kind of whatever wasn't she was an
Annihilation wasn't she uh V for
Vendetta I thought she was greater than
that I actually liked her in the Star
Wars prequels as Princess Amidala
[__] that she was great the
professional she had a thankless role in
that movie though I have to say yeah
poor thing although I tell you what the
prequels aged well compared to some of
the new [__] [__] that came out as
confusing I'm gonna have to disagree I
don't know man the [__] I liked him even
less like when I watched them again
recently
I gotta admit I liked
um Force awakens I thought that that was
going to be something decent
the second one nah [__] no and then that
very third one what was it called
uh uh it tried to [__] make up for
the disappointment of the second one but
it was just a jumbled confused mess
even though I liked some of the [__]
that was in it
but it was just
I don't know no new Star Wars [__]
sex the Mandalorian was great [__]
first and second season I heard the
season three evidently blows
but first and second season on
Mandalorian supposed to be really good
are not supposed to be uh was really
good
the third is supposed to not be very
good but I'll I'll
kind of Reserve judgment until I see it
myself although I'm not gonna [__]
pay Disney for it
somebody's gonna send me a [__]
Blu-ray
John Robertson said hey guys just became
a patron for you guys thank you guys
thank you that's awesome thank you hope
it can help you guys out oh it it will
don't worry about that we're not going
to end the show we're just opening up
other branches to other stuff it'll
it'll all cross promote yeah like I said
I don't really ever want to stop doing
this show we like the show I mean I have
I have a lot of fun yeah yeah I wish we
could do more to be honest yeah I wish I
could do more movie reviews per week
because we used to do a lot of movie
reviews I gotta get Jenny back in the
house she
working remotely and everything yeah the
money's good but we we can do that I'm
hoping we can do that from here and that
way we have more time to create our own
content I feel like I'm pimping her out
to these [__] dudes she's
drawing playgrounds for companies and
[__] all kinds of whatever the kind
of tacky [__] are you doing tacky it's
attacking playgrounds and parks and [__]
it's corporate stuff
yeah and that's just that's just not her
let me go to the restroom uh yeah he
said uh Jen abominable Dr fives Dr fives
is my favorite Vincent Price movie did
we review that we watched it when Sophie
was here not this last time but the time
before because that is also her favorite
pizza price movie as it happens so um
but I don't remember if we reviewed it
maybe we haven't I wanted to do if we
did a review of it I wanted to do like a
double feature and like I wanted to do
you know the first one on the second one
I think my I don't know my favorite
Vincent Bryce movie is probably God he
was in so many good ones I really really
love and maybe this is Lane but I really
do love the Roger Corman uh Poe movies
and particularly mask of the Red Death I
think that's probably my favorite and it
is that's like my favorite Poe story too
and I really like the way they
visualized it and you know he was
[__] great in that but I also I also
have a soft spot for House on Haunted
Hill
I really like Vincent Price in that and
I've seen that a million times too and
I've also seen like the rip tracks
version and stuff
um
John Gore said he could put some
greystones bats and skeletons in the
playgrounds I could
Zach says uh I re-watched the first
season of True Detective the other day
and uh it's still so good holy [__] yeah
um I would actually like to give that a
re-watch we watched it not too long ago
but
uh yeah John Robinson said the Raven was
good too of the Corman movies yeah all I
really really like that whole post cycle
like they were all good
uh Sebastian says the fly yeah that's
right like the original one
I don't think we've done the Raven
either we did Mask of the Red Death I'm
pretty sure
I'm trying to think of like the poe
Corman movies that we did I know we did
Mask of the Red Death yeah
um did we do Pit in the pendulum I don't
think we did fit in the pendulum now as
I was leaving to go to the restroom
we're talking about fives I liked fives
and it was kind of like the British
[__] psychedelic hippie drugged out
[__] horror comedy
fantasy that was a great [__] movie I
liked it
I liked how they did that
I want to see that one again like I said
I don't think we ever did a formal
review on it I remember watching it
when Sophie was here remember because
Sophie wanted to watch it yeah that's
like her favorite yeah it's just this
[__]
diabolical serial killer kinda
in some ways kind of like uh
um [__] who is the [__]
a serial killer lived down it's almost
kind of like almost kind of like [__]
The Phantom of the Opera that kind of
character yeah and uh
he's hip and 60s
but also kind of gossed out and he's
killing people and all these [__]
inventive ways and then he's got a lair
and a plan uh what was the plan with the
sarcophagus he was into getting that
and kill himself is that what it was
something like I had to see it again I
had to see it again been a while it's
been a while I think it was a couple
years ago yeah yeah it was pretty good
John Gore said tomb of Ligia is my
favorite I actually wanted to do a
review of Tomb of legendia because that
was just man it was on it was on shutter
it was on 2B or something like that and
I just saw it like a few weeks ago like
scrolling through and I was like oh [__]
yeah we should probably do that one too
um yeah John Robertson said my friend
finally watched Dr fives and he was like
what the [__] did I watch it it's just
so [__] weird [__] I think the most
recent Vincent Price movie that I
reviewed like you didn't review it with
me because you didn't watch it but um I
reviewed the Anthology movie uh twice
told Tales which was like adaptations of
like Nathaniel Hawthorne stories
um so I think that was the last Vincent
Price one that I did
because I've done a few on my channel on
my well it's on this channel but Vibes
kind of reminded me of that damn rock
opera that's what yeah it always like
reminds me of that what was the name of
that rock opera where it was yeah like
Phantom of the Opera but it was Phantom
of The Paradise Phantom of The Paradise
kind of reminded me of that
which is a good I want to see that again
they had good music and everything I
really like original songs but they
sounded like rock songs from the 70s
yeah yeah and it had like um what's her
name like uh Jessica Jessica Harper is
that right for like for Suspiria the
original susparian we're gonna have hit
the musical against into Phantom of The
Paradise [__] Sergeant Pepper's
Lonely Heart Club Band now see we've
we've reviewed Phantom of The Paradise
yeah but we haven't done Sergeant
Pepper's Lonely Hearts Club Band we're
gonna have to [__] we're gonna have
to probably do that one because I you
know it's a terrible movie like
objectively but I I still love it I
still love it it's a guilty I'm not
guilty about it I'm telling you right
now I I've I know it's terrible it's the
BG's and and [__] Aerosmith and
[__] Alice Cooper doing Beetle thumbs
beetles covers but doing like a whole
weird but doing a like narrative like a
[__] Beatles style narrative about Mr
Mustard and all kinds of weird [__] and
[__] come back [__] all that kind
of and it it kind of makes sense but
it's like a long music video
of of Beatles covers by 70s hit greatest
yeah artists yeah it's good like I said
I love it
it's tacky and it's kind of it is but
that's what I like about it it's low
production value but when you're
drinking you just [__] love it
because like star in the Bee Gees they
sing [__] half the songs at least
well yeah because they're like the main
characters yeah Peter Frampton's in it
too yeah that's right Peter Frampton
it's Peter Frampton and the baby yeah
they they are actually the titular yeah
yeah lonely hearts club bands yeah yes
it is who they are and I gotta say it's
good kind of like kind of like Xanadu I
like Xanadu
a fan sent a Xanadu for review yeah I
[__] loved it yeah it's good musical
yeah Olivia Newton John and super fun I
still I still love that um that magic
song yeah yeah and it's good it's about
a Greek goddess a muse
come to Earth to [__]
help [__] dudes become creative and
[__] and she did the [__] over
Generations
it's a good story
Zach says despite being a recent Bee
Gees convert I'm still scared to watch
Sergeant Pepper no no see Sergeant
Pepper's dude get loaded get loaded and
watch Sergeant Peppers you'll love it
you'll love it I mean maybe gay as [__]
I love it it is gay as [__] you'll love
it it's bad but I still but I love it
yeah it's gay as [__] it's bad in like a
really so gay it's almost drag okay it's
almost dry oh maybe oh yeah [__] you
couldn't drag queens with love oh George
Burns is in it too oh and Steve Martin's
in it too yeah Steve Martin Maxwell
silver is in Silver Hammer yeah yeah
Midge yeah he's in it Steve Martin me
and Jen used to hang [__] at a drag
Club but they'd have goth Knight there
it's called [__] Southern Nights here
in Florida I think it's still open it's
still there but they don't have the goth
night there anymore no and it was a
place was decked out it's like paradise
all right that was a cool place yeah I
mean Zach would have been that [__]
[__] singing Kevin Friday songs and
[__]
and I had a theater in it and everything
[__] yeah a little stage with colored
lights and [__] and this part of it was
inside and outside had a nice patio out
yeah it was like it was nice and uh it
didn't look like hardly anything from
the outside but the inside was found
normally it was drag all right oh they
would have played the [__] out of
[__] Sergeant Pepper's Lonely Heart
Club [__] band you could have had a
Sergeant Pepper's night themed night and
them drag queens
you could have done it they would have
showed up with that [__] man they should
do a whole oh man yeah they should do
that they should do like because they
were doing because there's so many
anyway there's so many costumes you
could do from that movie yeah like you
could be one of the weird robots with
like the weird like um yeah like the the
hair that they had that was kind of like
a like a scouring pad yeah that was the
uh they were kind of like uh black
female cylons remember the silence
Battlestar Galactica and they had the
[__] their their hair were wires yeah
they were gloss black and their eyes lit
up and [__] and they were [__] Mr
Mustard it's [__]
girls that helped him run the [__]
run his [__] hot dog [__] vehicle
remember that it wasn't it a vehicle
that was shaped like a hot dog I don't
think it was shaped like a hot tub
mustard on it I thought it was like a
bus like a bus yeah a bus shaped like a
hot dog with mustard on it I think
that's how I remembered it I haven't
seen it in a while and he had I thought
it was just a regular yellow they were
like two female
C-3PO Androids
yeah [__] sing they were good
characters
it's pretty trippy I mean his trip we're
not making we're not making it up this
stuff does actually just gotta see it to
understand
and then they had Alice Cooper doing the
brainwashing
yeah on all the you just gotta see this
[__] to understand yeah it does not make
sense outside the context of that movie
but in in the context of the movie
Sergeant Pepper's well they just cobbled
together like a bunch of Beatles songs
which like I said to make a narrative
which they wrote tripping balls yeah so
then they like made it tried to make it
into like a plot yeah and you can
imagine how that went
[Laughter]
well yeah like I said
very entertaining I really like that I
saw it a zillion times grow because they
used to show it on HBO like when I was a
kid yeah like all the time yeah all the
time
we know talking about I was talking
about what sex robots shouldn't look
like shouldn't look like real people
that's on Candy Valley right I was
thinking they should look more like Mr
Mustard's [__] yeah see that could I
could get by because they were they were
kind of sexy but they didn't look like
real people but they didn't look like a
person yeah yeah I get it well like I
said we were talking about the same
thing we were talking about the dildos I
said I don't really want like a
realistic looking dildo like you said it
was kind of like some Jeffrey Dahmer
[__] yeah like you got like distant full
of dicks
hanging around your house that look real
she looks stylized that's a little uh
I'm moving sure if you guys don't know
what we're talking about is that's you
know
for stream mate performances and [__]
video stuff that we've been doing on the
sides I don't know if you're new to the
show or not but we're not talking about
yeah I didn't want a dildo it's for
business purposes
they're for props for certain videos
yeah yeah we got a bunch of like got a
bunch of crazy like it wins all right
[__]
I look at I'm looking at my [__] this
I'm looking at my [__] Amazon and I
spent over a hundred dollars in dildos
and I said man these [__] are
looking at me like I'm [__] crazy
for me
I'm gonna start getting all kinds of
[__] weird you're gonna start getting
all kind of weird [__] now
yeah I still want that tentacle one but
um okay but we'll get that one next
payday we've got a lot of [__] I gotta
put I gotta we gotta pay for it and we
gotta get another camera that's true
that's 170. John Gore said the magic
Christian is a trip with uh Peter
Sellers and Ringo Starr I remember
seeing that yeah I remember liking that
there was a movie [__] sellers made
that I loved her as a kid I want to see
it again it was called The Return of the
Pink Panther oh right right yeah where
he plays [__] Dr Fu man [__] you know
the fetish plot of Dr Fu Manchu that's
what I'm thinking of where he plays Fu
Manchu I don't know I'm not even sure
that movie might be bad now because
she's playing a Chinese character I
don't [__] know you can still get all
those you're probably still good yeah
I've seen like um but all the Pink
Panther movies were great and so was
being there I [__] loved it I want to
get that that was another one we need to
review because I [__] love that movie
yeah I just saw I think it was on HBO
Max and I was like I was like dude it's
on HBO Max we should totally review it
but then like we watch something else
and we didn't really want to do it I
don't know if it's on there anymore yeah
uh John Robertson said I want the ghosts
of Christopher Lee Peter Cushing and
Vincent Price to read me bedtime stories
around my bed at night how [__]
awesome would that be I saw an interview
with Christopher Lee it turns out I
didn't know this Ian Fleming who wrote
007 was his cousin yeah yeah I didn't
know that I think we mentioned that we
did a show about
um Peter Cushing and Christopher Lee and
um I'm pretty sure I mentioned that on
there if I didn't I meant to like it was
in my notes for sure yeah and [__]
Christopher Lee was taught saying yeah
the stuff he was talking about was
Specter and things that he'd wrote about
in his other books he was he was saying
it was about these oligarchs that were
meeting up in a hotel here in Europe I
was like [__] so Specter is the
bilderberger that's that's who he was
talking about
wild [__] it's true
John Gore said I still gotta watch
Hercules in New York with Arnold uh
Arnold Schwarzenegger yeah yeah I think
they dubbed Arnie though yeah I remember
or vaguely remember it as a kid seeing
it and was disappointed with it
kind of like I I went out and spent good
money to get raw deal because as a kid I
remember liking it the movie Raw Deal it
sucks it's terrible
remember the artist I barely remember it
I saw it on cable Jim Belushi and yeah
that's right it's a cop movie and it's
terrible
I remember it's called raw no it's
called red heat
red heat and then I saw a raw deal too
he did that one and that one also sucked
he played a cop in it
but then Terminator came out and
predator and that changed Arnold's
[__] uh career uh Conan of course
[__] great although
when you hit Arnie said he had a
schedule of all these movies he had to
make he got hired simultaneously for
like nine movies and he didn't know
which ones were the good ones or which
ones were bad ones he just did them all
and some of them were [__] hits other
ones are just kind of Forgotten red heat
and Raw Deal were forgotten but I got
him
they're classics
and [__]
I'm a big fan of [__] um Total Recall
and what was the other one running man I
liked running man even though they cut
all the violence out of it but
I like Running Man Too
classic [__] the the last of the Great
Arnold Schwarzenegger's retro movies was
I think it's called like um
[__] what was the name of that the fifth
day or sixth day about genetic
engineering it's good I like it I like
it it had uh the dude who played uh
dude who played Merle
what was his name Merle from uh from
Walking Dead Walking Dead what was that
guy's name
he also was like [__] Henry portion
of a serial killer yeah he's in it
what's that guy's name from Mississippi
well I can't remember now [__] you guys
don't remember
um
so I recommend sixth day if you like
classic Arnold that was the last Arnold
Schwarzenegger movie what about Maggie
we liked that no no that that's a good
movie that's not an Arnold
Schwarzenegger movie really that's not a
classic Arnold Schwarzenegger movie no
that's true that's not an action movie
no and the the last classic one was the
sixth day and I liked it
all right so it's getting late I gotta
go to bed yeah let's shut it down it's
like 9 15. yeah uh but yeah so hopefully
you guys enjoyed this discussion about
that started out about it haunting but
always like goes into other things like
John said erasers okay yeah eraser was
okay a lot better than what was that
collateral damage collateral damage
[__] sucked eraser was a little bit
better better but not as good as [__]
um
was it true romance no True Lies True
Lies was a lot better uh what was the
one where he was fighting the devil yeah
[__] uh I got that one too last end
of days that one was awful I thought it
was terrible although Gabriel Byrne
rocked in it but Gabriel burn is always
good at everything that was really the
only I think I saw that in the theater
and I was just like man this is terrible
Sebastian says yeah I think it was
another uh sixth day was another uh
[__]
and I think that's his best one
in terms of the late movies late Arnold
movies now Maggie was
a good zombie movie based on acting also
the one with the with the what was the
the [__] uh airplane crash yeah yeah
that was pretty good too but that's just
Arnold's showing that he could he can
act now yeah but those were not classic
Arnold Schwarzenegger style action
movies
right yeah all right so we're gonna wrap
it up so I can get to bed and get up
early in the morning like I usually do
so thanks everybody for dropping by
thanks for your super chats and thanks
for our new Patron John that's really
really awesome
so we are gonna be back on Wednesday
night for our regular Our Big Show live
stream and the topic this week is gonna
be
good old Brenda Spencer one of the very
few female Mass Shooters uh this is
known as the I guess the Cleveland
school shooting or the I Don't Like
Mondays shooting uh the Boomtown Rats
wrote a song about it happened back in
the 70s so uh so yeah so that's what
we're gonna be talking about on
Wednesday night's show so that should be
really interesting so hopefully you guys
can drop by for that so yeah uh have a
good rest of your evening you guys and a
good day tomorrow and we'll see you
again on Wednesday night good